what's the best way to deal with
feedback you don't agree with my manager
give my manager gives me feedback on my
personality that I don't agree with I'm
only in the company five months and he
doesn't know enough about me to make the
comments he's making I find myself
wanting a con want to contest with what
he's saying but I believe this will
ultimately end poorly for me it's
frustrating for me to listen to feedback
from him about my personality when my
friends and family would disagree with
him okay again this is one of those
questions that I think people that
listen the podcast know what the answer
is what you do when someone's giving you
feedback did you listen to it and you
try and make adjustments get in their
head and figure out where this is coming
from they're obviously saying this for
some reason and maybe the reason is
because they have a big ego or they
don't understand people very well and
that's fine and if you know that then
you just learned something about them
but also you might not know yourself as
well as you think you do and and
obviously if you can test what someone's
saying you're gonna look like you can't
take critiques oh you're right that's
not a good approach to take furthermore
what you're saying is that your friends
and family wouldn't agree with this guy
well guess what they're your friends and
family right it's like the dude's mom
that you know the dude's mom always
thinks the dudes handsome dudes not
handsome but his mom thinks he's
handsome and he you know your friends
and family think oh I can't believe
they'd say that about you
well that's your friends and family
there's a reason why you have friends
because they like you yeah
they whatever part of your personality
is is not cool they're over it yeah well
this this boss the manager can't deal
with it he has know how to deal with it
yet so like I said when someone gives
you a critique you should actually
listen to so what people have such a
hard time with and you should actually
listen and say okay well maybe I'm too
aggressive maybe I'm you know too
close-minded or whatever or whatever
critique point you're getting listen to
him maybe someone's like hey I don't
think you take
very well in yulik were you talking
about of course I take critique well you
don't know that's my point
so and the other thing like I said is in
doing this the managers actually telling
you something about their personality
and and their views and their judgment
so learn from that learn what they're
pretty they're teaching you about their
personality which is gonna help you
better influence and manipulate and work
with work with that person in the future
and perhaps help make them into a better
leader and a better supporter of what it
is that you're trying to do mmm so calm
down relax one of the best things you
can do when someone when someone says to
you hey I think you're screwing this up
it's a call hold on let me let me let me
grab a notebook I just want to take
notes to make sure I understand we were
coming from so I can I can make some
adjustments I'm always looking to get
better yeah that might be a little
extreme but you know hold on a second
let me get my notebook yeah so I can
take notes because I want to get better
yeah but no some people somebody they'll
take notes you know however you really
like taking notes I killed the llamas
when I was running the West Coast SEAL
training the the good officers like
there would be some officers when would
I'd be putting out word to him they'd be
taking notes
yeah that's gain and I was even when I
first saw it it was kind of like mmm
surprise me yeah okay this guy's just
straight-up taking notes on what I'm
telling he's a one-on-one conversation
because he's sitting there like taking
notes yeah yeah so that get some but if
you said it with your tone like hold on
all jock was gonna say something let me
get out my notebook yeah that's
sarcastic yeah yeah but there's also not
just being sarcastic I was leaning
towards more like the brown noser oh
that guy okay oh oh I go you're gonna
give me some feedback hold on one second
I want to get my notes out so I can make
sure I do exactly what you're telling me
to do thanks buddy
yeah again with the tone yeah I think
you know there's a little way middle
ground I think yeah who is it Sarah
Armstrong I think put it out on Twitter
something about tone and body language
in some psychological survey makes
more than half what is actually being
said yeah and I heard that too
and I was like hey that sounds cool but
I mean you know maybe maybe not because
if someone says something it's pretty
clear but then I it's kind of stuck with
me and it's true but I could literally
say the same like I don't know ten words
to you in all these different tones and
they would mean ten different things oh
for sure like you can like it's actually
baffling in surprising how much we can
actually communicate like if I if I make
a joke to you like something you don't
know my level of sarcasm you don't know
necessarily you have to know the person
you know like so there's all these
things that that have to be in place for
you to effectively be communicated to
yeah so like let's say you overhear a
conversation in the next room like you
could easily miss the whole point of the
conversation even though you heard every
word because you don't know if they're
joking you don't know if they're serious
you don't know if one guy's mad you know
if one is getting older and they can
take the same exact or they can say the
same exact words but they're just saying
different things coming from differently
that's where you would end up a lot of
communication problems with the email
yeah where someone emails a joke yeah
joking about something and if someone
takes it seriously and next thing you
know people are flying off the handle
yeah I always had that rule in my seal
platoon isn't asking if you weren't
allowed to joke on the radio yeah the
main reason for that rules cuz you you
don't want other people outside your
organization to hear it and take it the
wrong way same thing but it's the same
thing with email unless you know someone
really really well that's really really
well you better it's better to keep the
sarcastic comments and just be
straightforward and speak plainly you're
an email when you're communicating with
people it's a lot it's a lot easier and
then even with that the prophet has no
escape from this even with that you
could easily come off as like too rigid
or me or that dang is this guy this guy
not like yeah you know like that's your
second email and it's like that's why
communication is important that's why
learning how to to write well is
important that's why little words that
you put in matter into phrases into
sentences they matter yeah a difference
thus the invention of emojis
memo's yeah no you're very into emojis I
am now yeah I sometimes I I i must say
that i think you communicate very well
with emojis because even though you
don't sometimes use any words in a text
to me i fully understand what you mean
mm-hmm
bye lightning bolt lightning bolt
lightning bolt rainbow rainbow lightning
bolt thumbs up sucka fire shaaka fire
yeah very clear right yeah no I uh yeah
yeah I agree yeah I agree with that
shaaka fire I forgot about fire you do
quite a bit of fire yeah the lightning
bolt and fire I use in them the chakra
for sure and the rain with you I use a
rainbow a lot seems like a child thing
don't you know like emoticons
I don't like emojis yeah but you're kind
of like that in real life you know I
know but it's it seems like to me it's
see yeah it's like a kid maybe your
little daughter would do it or something
it's what my daughter will send me 875
emojis from my wife's phone yeah yeah
all of them see if she can yeah and I
send back okay yeah yeah see buddy
you're like that in real life too though
that's the thing like if you like if you
you know that you're running the risk of
sounding too like you know like stoic or
whatever you know like if you if you
have to answer a question with yes when
in whatever the question is it's a
yes-or-no question and you answer yes
affirmative ly right it you'll put yes
period and that'll come off as like a
joke was like I don't know whatever this
guy is serious or something you know
instead of yes exclamation point yes -
exclamation points lightning bolt fire
info or something like that that gives
away a little bit more like you know
you're just like yes is as if you're
just looking someone in their eye you're
going yes that's that's it
I know that's what I'm saying you really
like that in real life right on
lightning bolt fire yeah man let's
emojis know I'm in there don't over do a
double Shaka double shock yeah
what's the highest level of a mood emoji
approval you can send me three lightning
bolts three fires three chakras 3
rainbows sure like you shouldn't do 4 4
is dumber
you know Oh depends on what I say though
so like if there is if it's a word or
the vowel in the word will they'll be
like that's that can be infinite like if
I put it I don't know you know like
you'll tell me something exciting and
I'll put it not and all but dang instead
of D ing I'll put D lowercase a
depending the level of excitement a that
can go infinitely by the way that can
spend 20 text messages even over 20 days
and that's how infinite it can be then
the first half of that is in lowercase
the second half of the A's are uppercase
the N maybe 10 ends 3 G's all capital
then you know then so because it just
depends
yes well like I said I think you
communicate well on a serious note in
regards to communication that is
effective you know what I mean you sense
my level of excitement as opposed to
cool period yeah yeah no no your mother
you were anyway next question
I guess the rainbow of I